et pour débuter je vous propose tout de
suite de partir dans les rues de saint
quentin en yvelines où nous sommes allés
poser cette question et ont libre
d'écrire ce que l'on veut c'est
forcément de circonstance voici votre
point de vue tout à fait on a le droit
d'écrire ce que l'on veut ce très
important c'est la liberté d'expression
et c'est fondamental
ou alors tant qu'on a la liberté
d'expression on peut dire qu'on est
libre dans notre pays le jour où on a
plus de liberté d'expression c'est ce
qui se passe dans les dictatures tout
écrire ben non il ya quand même des
choses à faire attention par rapport aux
religions tout ça faut pas dire
n'importe quoi et
et voilà moi j'estime que enfin faut
être correct faut respecter chaque
religion et puis c'est tout je suis pour
la liberté d'expression ça choque mais
après il faut s'expliquer la personne
doit se dire pourquoi il a dit ça et
l'autre pourquoi ça choquait et ça se
peut que ce sur malentendu que
l'autre qu'il est choqué mais insiste
licka je pense qu'il pourra comprendre
le point de vue de l'autre la liberté
d'expression c'est important de pouvoir
en bénéficier en france ça semble
commune comme une évidence et ce n'est
pas forcément une évidence dans
l'ensemble des pays quand vous voyez
qu'en france on est très attaché à la
possibilité d'écrire ce que l'on veut et
il faut garder préserver cette liberté
ça doit forcément vous satisfaire et
vous dire qu' il existe des pays où
c'est possible bien sûr ces sachants
jeffrey d'après ce que j'ai connu et
surtout votre jeunesse où tout était
contrôlé fustigé est puni cerveau et oui
on travaille dans la sérénité
pratiquement pour exprimer ce qu'on
avait à dire
la maison de la poésie et mobilisés à
l'occasion de cette journée consacrée
aux écrivains persécutés il ya eu des
interventions dans les classes on va en
parler et puis il ya également une
soirée dès ce soir et intervenir
plusieurs écrivains
oui les quatre écrivains qui sont
intervenus dans les lycées à
l'université aujourd'hui gérald
bloncourt casam shahriari matéi visniec
evans 13 cov quatre poètes quatre pays
quatre histoires et des lits seront ce
soir avec le musicien mahmoud de mire
plus de musiciens turcs musiciens de
jazz avec madame demandions qui
représente amnistie internationale et
jean-luc des sparks le président du pe n
club france justement pour amnesty
international il était également
important de se mobiliser vous
intervenez avec amnesty international
régulièrement vous faites venir et pas
forcément des écrivains mais en france
intervienne et des gens qui sont
persécutés au quotidien pour avoir
exprimé leur opinion et c'est un message
en france qui est qu'il est facile à
entendre et à faire comprendre
oui oui le ski est plus difficile c'est
de se faire entendre dans les pays
concernés et même parfois de mobiliser
dans ces pays
le réseau d'amnesty suffisamment
puissant pour pour faire entendre sa
voix auprès des différents dirigeants
mais il est vrai que la liberté
d'expression m dans les pays auxquels on
pense d'abord les pays autoritaires les
régimes totalitaires les les
gouvernements jouent un peu avec la le
le côté ambiguë de la liberté
d'expression parce que même ici en
france on n'a pas le droit de tout dire
la liberté d'expression a des limites
la première d'entre elles serait sans
doute celle de respecter la liberté des
autres ne pas ne pas s'exprimer de
manière à inciter la haine raciale par
exemple où elle ou même dans certains
pays et c'est ça qui est difficile
veillez au respect des valeurs morales
plus qu'évident et religieuses qui ne
sont pas les mêmes partout en cours vous
vous êtes d'accord avec ce discours on
ne peut pas tout dire non plus il ya une
limite à l'expression personnellement je
pense que on peut tout dire
c'est une question de responsabilité par
rapport à ce qu'on dit bref pour ce
conte écrit par rapport au contraire
qu'on peut avoir
et moi je vais des photos mes photos
sont publiées dans la presse mais à vie
à certaines scènes que je ne
photographie pas parce que journal peut
tomber sous les yeux d'un enfant est une
espèce de responsabilité d'homme d'image
l'autocensure forcément forcément il ya
eu des interventions dans les classes
cet après midi on les a évoqué
brièvement geneviève nos rêves vous êtes
enseignante dans votre classe cet après
midi il ya des écrivains des gens qui
s'expriment aussi par la photographie
qui sont intervenus comment s'est passée
les changes avec les plus jeunes
mais les changes s'est très bien passé
ils ont pris conscience justement qui
avait un lien entre la littérature et la
liberté d'expression et je pense que ça
c'était intéressant pour eux ils se sont
rendus compte que les mots était une
arme
en fait ils en ont pris conscience
surtout effectivement avec le témoignage
de ce thème at il vise n'est qu'un qui
est venu donc il leur a raconté
justement son histoire en roumanie ils
ont écouté avec beaucoup d'attention et
d'ailleurs ils ne voulaient plus quitter
à la fin ils ont fini par une discussion
d'une heure on a dû fermer
l'établissement pour laisser laisser
partir on va l'écouter justement cet
intervenant écrivain journaliste roumain
arrivé en france en 1987 comme réfugié
politique auteur interdit est censuré
dans son pays d'origine
l'intervention au micro de johanna
soudry j'ai toujours décrit autour des
rapports individuels et le pouvoir
ça m'a toujours intéressée de penser de
réfléchir à la manière dont le pouvoir
mal écrit les individus on oublie
parfois qu il à une époque où le seul
espace de liberté était la littérature
il a des auteurs qui sexy mais il ya des
auteurs qui résiste toujours sur place
qui risque aussi parfois la persécution
mais encore une fois pour résumer la
littérature a été toujours toujours d'un
espace de liberté et par son côté
subversive et la toujours dérangé le
pouvoir totalitaire et c'était au lycée
mais les bretelles cet après midi la
précision est importante d'un port ni
parce que ça fait partie des
établissements avec lesquels on
travaille depuis très longtemps c'est
pas la première fois vous avez déjà
organisé sa dent ni talent intervention
c'est la deuxième fois que nous
travaillons sur la journée des poules
est emprisonné c'est la deuxième fois
que la maison de la poésie de travail
sur les poètes emprisonné aussi même si
la manifestation existe depuis très
longtemps mais c'est une des journées
internationales dont on ne parle
absolument pas ce que je disais toujours
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire mesure
faste après midi très surprenant dans le
pays des droits de l'homme
justement ces élèves sans surprise comme
en parle assez peu il connaissait cette
journée par exemple il connaissait cette
journée parce que je leur en ai parlé
parce que nous avons fait aussi une
exposition prêtée par la maison de la
poésie donc dans le hall du lycée
oui c'est une prise de conscience pour
eux qui me semblent importantes
ils se rendent compte qu'ils se rendent
compte qu'il faut toujours être engagée
réfléchir gérald on court on va coûter
votre témoignage aussi parce que vous
êtes intervenu auprès des plus jeunes 7
après bien sûr mais j'ai des conseils
passés cet échange de votre point de vue
cette fois ci de mon point de vue moi je
crois que je me suis enrichi parce
qu'elle a quelques réflexions et des
intervenants et j'étais très émue et
dans le groupe k dieu mais pour m et
c'était je croyais ne jamais l'avoir
écrit moi-même tellement c'était dit
avec des genevois de voix très fraîche
et très très bien dis donc c'est une
expérience mais qui m'a beaucoup ému et
je veux je n'ai pas de mots pour
exprimer leurs riches issement qui matin
vous et dès qu'on a ce type de contact
on va découvrir un chiffre à présent qui
va s'afficher c'est le chiffre de cette
édition vingt 20 ans vous aviez 20 ans
quand vous avez été expulsé d'haïti vous
étiez l'un des principaux leaders des
cinq glorieuses
c'était à 46,46 746 vous étiez l'un des
cinq principaux leaders des cinq
glorieuses un journées révolutionnaires
qui ont entraîné la chute du
gouvernement de l'escaut comment vous
avez vécu cette situation alors vous
n'aviez pas encore 20 ans justement mais
écoutez je crois qu'on était muré depuis
très jeune et on a été tellement
affrontés à toutes les injustices
sociales et à toutes les violences et de
l'arbitraire les différents pouvoirs qui
se susurre succéder à violence on a eu
les l'occupation américaine est très
jeune on était déjà adulte en esprit on
réfléchissait ont cherché à savoir
comment changer les choses ce qui
aboutit à nos actions de 46 et au
renversement du gouvernement laisse qu
ensuite vous êtes arrivée peu de temps
après en france ensuite
la polonaise il
début d'exil qui a commencé en
martinique pendant deux mois et demi je
connais césaire glissant et tout ce
monde là et j'ai eu l'autorisation du
ministre marius moutet mini de la france
d'autres maires de rater la france ou
que j'ai rejoué où j'avais de la famille
guadeloupéenne qui étaient présentes
dont l'exil mais a été un peu moins dur
puisque j'avais pour me loger mais il a
fallu vu débarquer des cageots alvand
exemple et je voyais je rejoignais le
pays
mon frère aîné m'avait précédé en 1938 a
été exécuté par les nazis au mont
valérien
1 le neuf en 1942 donc tout ça c'était
aussi un peu mon pays on voit
quelques-unes de vos photos on a montré
quelques uns de vos clichés parce que
vous êtes devenu ensuite
photo photo reporter vous été gracié des
photojournalistes tout à fait par hasard
j'ai rencontré j'ai un job dans une
boîte de photographies où j'ai commencé
avec la grosse pomme 18-24 angie
ce succès d'ennahda recrues je disais et
puis j'ai découvert qu'il était possible
de dire la vie des hommes dans leur plus
grande vérité j'étais photographe
allumage donc été créée sa politique du
service photo de l'humanité service
votre nouvel observateur l'express le
nouvel économiste
regard syndicalisme hebdo témoignage
chrétien +17 revue d'ailleurs quel j'ai
collaboré des éditeurs aussi nathan et
compagnie et je n'ai pas arrêté moi j'ai
deux cent mille photos que j'ai recopié
ce que j'ai vu je veux que mes rides
je n'ai fait que recopier ce que gvg
décembre les photos que j'exploite il se
fait ben jelloun et je suis rentré dans
l'informatique dès le départ et je
compte bien les exploiter elles sont
tellement départ des chercheurs des
historiens des écrivains et a continué
publiés presque hebdomadaire mode les
journaux actuelle dans libération
l'humanité l'autre journaux et voilà
rien et des publications des livres
aussi également et sans nous avons
quelques joueurs dans le moche moche ou
qui est le pari de gérald bloncourt qui
ont voté non rien chez au paris où j'ai
mis un peu ce que
nous avons la pression sur paris qui
n'est pas des choses à la rose
et puis une série de personnalités que
j'ai pu rencontrer pressurage parce que
je vous ai vu un très bel ouvrage acheté
l'année dernière
en le voyant j'avais participé -déjà-
donc à une soirée où vous étiez présent
monsieur concours et c'est vrai que j'ai
acheté en fait votre ouvrage pour
l'offrir à mon père qui a le même âge
que vous et donc j'étais ravi de lui
faire revivre
voilà ce pari et ce regard si certains
juillet photo g il ya connu l'exil
également continuer à dérouler de brière
sont malheureusement mais votre
biographie biographie en 1986 vous êtes
retourné en sept ans alors dès la chute
de la dictature j'ai terminé une
campagne que nous avions fait le capal
du livre où nous avions collecté 1
million de livres que nous avons ramené
dans leurs pays et je suis rentré au
pays immédiatement et avec l'idée de
retourner définitivement ce mon avis et
lg fait quand même c'est faire onze
voyages
mais bon il reste pas 40 et impunément
sans avoir d'autre lien d'autres amours
j'avais des enfants
donc il a fallu que je fasse la lavette
et en ce moment je j'étais ya juste
avant le tremblement de terre en avant
j'étais un haïti est actuellement j'ai
quelques difficultés à y retourner parce
que comme je dénonce un peu beaucoup de
choses mais le complot dit c'est pas cet
engagement ne serait-ce qu'en 98 vous
êtes le cofondateur du comité pour la
défense des droits de l'homme et de la
démocratie en haïti
vous gardez cet engagement jouer on
continue dans trois quatre jours m'a
téléphoné des sites russe hindi
à ce propos nous sommes en liaison nous
dessert le groupe et nos forces pour
faire juger ce sanguinaire qui est
coupable
son père et lui de 60 mille victimes et
de toutes les exactions sont déroulées
dans le pays
quand mon tour j'ai dû venir les choses
et nous essayons de le faire juger pour
les crimes contre l'humanité c'est
important un tel témoignage me tourner
le directeur de la maison de la poésie
puis se poseraient la question également
pour amnesty international mais c'est
important de faire entendre un tel
témoignage c'est pour ça que vous avez
décidé de vous y associer oui celui de
gerald comme celui de kazem shahriari
qui a traversé le désert en iran pour
ceux arrivés au
au pakistan est ensuite arrivée en
france comme celui de gérald eu de matéï
visniec qui a dû quitter qui a décidé de
quitter la roumanie parce qu'il ne
pouvait plus vivre là bas il n'y avait
plus rien à faire je reste important
surtout que ça vient d'écrivains et de
poètes qui qui porte la parole du monde
d'aujourd'hui
même s'ils ont écrit des textes comme
gérald à l'âge de 19 ans 46 leur parole
est encore très vive aujourd'hui
et moi je suis je suis en admiration
devant ces gens là et je suis très
heureux que aujourd'hui ces quatre
écrivains et pu rencontrer quelques 300
lycéens étudiants puisqu'il ya eu
plusieurs rencontres on a on a couru le
territoire toute la journée avec ma
collaboratrice catherine baron et on est
très heureux de ce qui a pu se faire
grâce à la collaboration des enseignants
des responsables ont participé à cet
établissement c'est c'est pour moi
c'était on était à deux établissements
l'an dernier 7 cette année on en fera 14
années prochaines
je patiente yamal coup mais je dresse
heide ce soir parce que sinon mais ça
c'est important parce qu'après il la
parole il faut là il faut l'entendre
aussi dans le public on n'est pas dans
le pathos on cherche pas à créer de
l'émotion pour l'émotion c'est pas le
but c'est que ces gens-là doivent sont
là pour non pas seulement pour parler
leur témoignage est des porteurs de
mémoire ce qu'ils sont mais aussi pour
donner de l'espoir parce que s'ils sont
là c'est parce que l'écriture les fait
tenir debout et moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est à dire debout là dans
le temps présent ils sont pas dans
l'imaginaire ils sont pas dans leur rêve
ils sont pas dans le dans une utopie
ils sont dans la création du monde
d'aujourd'hui et les quatre qu'on
accueille aujourd'hui comme les deux
qu'on avait accueilli l'an dernier ils
sont dans cet esprit là et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse je vous laisse le mot de la
fin pour amnesty international justement
au caire a ajouté
bien qu'oui pour convaincre les gens de
venir ce soir peut-être parce qu'il ya
tout de même cette soirée à la maison de
la poésie à guyancourt pour rencontrer
les différents auteurs à des heures à
écouter s'il n'est pas encore été
convaincue par les arguments de monsieur
fourni à croire que c'est possible
il ya encore il ya encore en lien avec
amnesty international et donc en lien
avec l'ensemble de nos actions à travers
le monde
mais le rôle des écrivains en tant que
témoin mettez moi on sens que 20 ils
sont au plus près des événements souvent
les gouvernements cachent leur rédaction
c'est très difficile d'avoir accès à des
informations et c'est par des personnes
notamment comme des écrivains des poètes
qui nous apportent des témoignages ou
même par exemple des travailleurs
humanitaires qui constate des crimes
contre l'humanité etc
quel est ce qui arrive à travailler et
donc les témoignages de tous et pleurait
de tous ces écrivains sont autant
d'éléments très précis tu aimes les skis
merci à tous les quatre d'être venu
merci également pour votre témoignage
sur ce plateau jarle donc merci merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau nous
poursuivrons le 7-8 on va parler
politique à présent le temps d'une
petite virgule et on en parle dans un
instant avec lima l'on doit notamment le
maire de trappes